do you want to hear the first
disappointing news of the day sure
it's it's not a big deal but it's it's
it's news to me
i was conned at the grocery store the
other day
conned those like easter eggs did you
see this
what's
is that like an eight ounce bottle yes
do you think those tiny ones like the
coronas it's seven
seven fluid ounces wow and i
i was like oh man i was at heb and i was
like
oh they got great deals on corona or on
dos equis here
dude what little did i realize
they weren't real
no say i don't know enough spanish to
get in on this bit
yo come on
ladies and gentlemen yeah keith means x
right
eckies yeah x is ecky
that's different than aki which is here
versus eki how much spanish do you know
jake
i figure you would know more than a
little yeah right yo
comprendo espanol no poquito there it is
all right i mean your wife's
first language is uh spanish isn't it
yep
yes it was yeah that's the first
language she wrote it's funny because
she
um still to this day you know
language like anything is a lifelong
learning process
and so still to this day um she'll have
little phrases in english that she'll
use that aren't quite right
you know even though she's been speaking
it for 30
plus years and so it's funny just
because
like i i i realize if i was in her shoes
i'd be the exact same way there'd
probably be things that i would be
saying
that wouldn't be quite little idioms and
stuff you know especially english is
such a quirky language
yeah yeah just little things with like
are you talking about like like phrases
or like sayings
yeah you know there's all these there's
all these english phrases that we use
that we don't think about like
um nip it in the bud nip it in the bud
see nico actually nico taught me that
one the other day i always thought that
was
nip it in the butt yeah but it's not
because it's
it's a plant thing yeah yeah yeah
yep oh speaking of which nico do you
have any of those like flowers green
flowers it's like planting foam it's
like green
styrofoam do you have a bunch of it not
a bunch of it something okay
for the satisfying render i want to like
cut some of it okay we're just in here i
think at the studio
do we because it's shot all right well
we've been rolling for the last three
minutes so i'm going to play the intro
play i literally have
jordan going to pick another right now
it just
[Music]
[Laughter]
here let me see if i can let me see if i
can trick the camera to think i'm not
playing no no it's an audio filter it's
the audio filter is so good these days
that it's
literally filtering out the guitar but
keeping your voice
yes the podcast listeners can hear it
wild but it's we cannot hear it so it
just sounds like
welcome to the podcast
no acoustics and now we're talking about
something i guess the listeners don't
get because they heard you just fine
yeah recorded i guess this is what it
would have this is what it would have
sounded like
welcome to the corridor cast we are here
to have a blast
[Laughter]
except you would have been pretending to
play the guitar in the video yeah
yeah that's it yeah
well man well ruined that intro yeah
that was a great interest
even better all right well i just got
back from the hospital yeah man
tell us about that what yeah um not me
personally um but i had to take my
daughter
because she's fine but uh she was
usually why i go to hospitals
she was on this little horse toy thing
mm-hmm
yeah now this thing i i i
i'm gonna need to serve justice onto
this little horse toy because it
it took my son's tooth and now it's and
now it's taken
my daughter's chin because
she just uh was on it and she was just
playing on it and she's a little too big
for it and i tell her not to play on it
but she was playing on it anyways
because i
was classic and uh and then she tipped
forward on it and
bonked her chin on the tile
and then obviously busted it open so she
just had to go get three stitches
wow oh man yeah wow that horse is out
for children's blood
yeah now she did great the stitches went
really well
and they did him super the the
physician's assistant that did them like
she did an amazing job they're super
straight very clean
and then they dissolve after five days
so wow
that's that but then we also had to take
because jj fell
on it like a like almost a year ago and
then he had this tooth that was chipped
and that and it was supposed to be fine
but it developed like
it wasn't it developed like a bacteria
or something like it wasn't
quite it didn't quite heal right so then
he had to have his tooth removed and now
because of this dang
toy horse
well anyways i suppose jj just has a gap
because they're just gonna wait for his
adult tooth to come in right
yes so now he's got this big old funny
gap between his teeth
whenever he smiles he's got this big old
missing tooth oh my god
i can't imagine what that's like for
parents how old is he
he's two and a half okay so not quite at
the age where he's losing teeth
naturally hmm
no yeah that'll be a few years yet so
he's gonna have that gap in his
mouth for years yeah at least until he's
in like third or fourth grade yeah
it's funny it's funny you mentioned that
too because i as a kid
before i got my adult teeth in um i was
like trying to do this cool like power
slide move on my bike
on my like it was like a tricycle bike
and like the older kids were doing it
down the steep hill
so i was like i could do this too i
don't i don't care i'm a kid
i've never had injuries or problems so i
go down the steep hill
and then just immediately like the the
bike buckles under me
and i hit smack my face like face first
on the concrete
and i when i get up i think my mom saw
this
and both of my front teeth were just
like dangling
out and they were just dangling dude
just like blood everywhere and yeah that
was a hospital vision
attitude and for about four
nerves for months and months
i had these two just missing front teeth
and i actually booked a disney
commercial from that
actually oh really yeah yeah it was it
was when they did the star wars weekends
when they first opened up star wars
um at uh like a couple years ago no can
we finally find
disney world they had like a star wars
thing can we find an official photo of
this
please oh my god yeah i'll find it i'll
try to get it down for you
in florida in disneyland florida disney
world in florida i went to the star wars
there back in the day yeah yeah because
they had it they had the park back there
yeah a long time ago
um i did not know so yeah so i did a
commercial never been to disneyland with
the
i was like asking for darth vader's
autograph and he signed it by
sticking his lightsaber through it so i
just had this hole in this
i know why they they hired you though
not because they thought the teeth were
cute but because they knew that they
wouldn't have to provide dental
insurance
yeah i'm sure that's what it was that's
exactly it
yeah and i don't know why that reminded
me of like i got thrown off a bike one
time when i was a kid
for a very different reason i was
totally fine so it's like it doesn't end
up bad it's not like
i don't have dangling teeth but this kid
threw a broom at my bike
like a spear like a javelin and went
straight through my front tire
and caught up in the in the spokes and
it just stopped my wheel dead i went
diving over the front of the bike
and i just remember being so angry i was
like you're an idiot like you're out of
your mind what'd you think would happen
yeah and i but then at the same time i
also can relate because it's like he
wasn't thinking
sure i do that all the time i will do
stuff impulsively without thinking
oh yeah we know exactly
why things in your mouth yeah it's
because i don't think
okay that actually brings something else
up there's a uh there's a crew cuts
uh it's attack on titan crew cuts on the
website for websites
um i literally like physically gagged
when you took a random stray cup of
coffee
and drank it you know those but for
anyone that
isn't aware there are just random mugs
throughout this this office
full of just nasty rank old coffee that
sometimes
you know better too ryan you know better
than to drink straight coffee that's
been sitting out for days i will say
that i think daniel embellished the
sound design around that
a little bit yeah you did drink it
though i i did
sip it i did it just like a little suit
just enough to prove that some of it
went in my mouth and it was it was just
cold coffee
i have no idea whose it was probably
christians or deans from vfx arts
reactions like the previous week
yeah christian's claiming the coffee
okay oh
i just it's more about like what i
pictured maybe it wasn't that gross but
just moldy coffee i've gotten good at
being able to do really gross things
in as not a gross way as possible okay
so you don't die or something yeah like
when i ate those twizzlers that were out
in the street puddle yeah you know like
i didn't eat them i just bit them
and just like made a show for cameron
then spat them out immediately still got
that bacteria in your mouth
dude the hunter street juice man i got
an infected wound because of hunter
street juice man
it was it was it was fresh after a rain
it was so diluted of fresh water
and it was just like a little bit of
water in my mouth and i spat it out
instantly it's like not that big of a
deal
it improved my immune system
[Laughter]
you're not going to convince me of that
no way but to go back to that bike
flipping over
the front thing that happened to me when
i was like i don't know
probably eight or so and i still have a
scar i don't know
really i thought you're gonna get a scar
usually that's how people break their
yeah i can't see it i i see hair there
is
when my hair is short there is there is
still a scar on the back of my mind
really from it
yeah wow so like did you get a
concussion or something like what
what happened i was riding my bicycle
and i thought that it would be a great
idea to try to use a large rock that was
in the road
as
[Laughter]
and instead my bike went like that and
my my body went over the front of it
and i just remember waking up in a
puddle of my own blood
oh no i was like eight or nine
okay and i and i stumbled back to my
house with blood all over myself
and my sister saw me like because we
lived in this rural like development
and my sister saw me from like down the
road
like walking with like a zombie with
blood on myself and she came running out
because my parents weren't home at the
time and she was seven years older than
i was so she was watching us
um and uh yeah that was
uh she's like oh no i'm responsible for
the zombie coming down the street
yeah thankfully i was fine but um
man yeah there was uh there was this
blood stain on the road
until they repaved it oh man really whoa
yeah dang man this is turned into like
personal injuries like nico do you have
like a crash story i mean i have did you
ever fall off of a bicycle as a kid no
i've never crashed really hard on a
bicycle to the point where i have like a
story about well nico there's still time
man you got that new electric bike yes
kind of getting into electric bikes um i
think it's the next bug that's biting me
really so yeah cool the uh did you get
did you go for assisted power or
a regular motor it's basically have two
options when it comes to electric bike
you either have the motor in the back
tire or the motor in the middle with the
pedals
they both kind of have their own perks
if the motor's in the middle with the
pedals
um you know it's going to make your
pedals go around but
you then get to utilize the whole gear
system
after the motor to influence that
motor's power so you can put that
motor's power towards torque for like
really steep hill climbs so i can put it
towards
you know basically cruise and go your
top gear uh top speed
top speed yeah and then it also but no
torque exactly but no torque
um so you can't like climb a hill
necessarily in your top gear unless it's
a really powerful motor
um and supposedly the weight's better
too if it's in your back tire it's a
little bit
easier to maintain i guess um and like
it's a little bit of a smoother ride
uh but there's no like there's no gears
little cheaper motors yeah um
but the uh you know you're going to get
that power output of the motor and
that's it
um so i actually ended up picking up an
electric mountain bike like two weeks
ago
um it was just like an all-in-one thing
just like a little like e-bike
distributor down and
and downey actually jake um
and it's jake used to live yeah we're
jackie slim it has a 350 watt
rear hub motor and now all the one wheel
and that we've done like i'm starting to
wrap my head around these so like the
first one wheel is a 500 watt motor
and the xr is a 750 watt motor
i believe um so this bike has a 350 watt
motor
and it's cool i really like it you can
go super fast
but when you're climbing a hill you
still have to put like 10 percent of
your effort into
it which sounds like i shouldn't be
complaining at all but
part of me really wants the experience
of
like total power right the ability to
like climb anything total power
total power it's a mountain bike well i
mean you can get like electric dirt
bikes like what sam has that sturon
yeah those are heavy those are heavy
that's 110 pounds
um by the way funny story i've actually
looked at bike up there's segway bikes
now
because yeah segway nine bot i think is
the company that yeah
and segway are actually both i think
subsidiaries are owned by another
company
which makes a lot of electric vehicles
and they bought segway back in like a
few years ago
um so they just rebranded their surround
bikes as segway bikes
and it's the exact same thing that
they're now selling under the segway
brand
yeah and that's it's interesting about
that too because it's like i was talking
with the flux movement guys with the
shop
in in little tokyo there they have one
in the in their window
yeah uh and they want to be able to sell
them but apparently uh
sharon or or at least sure on the as the
subsidiary brand has an exclusive
distribution deal with this other
company in la for like all of california
or something like that and so like
they actually can't sell those bikes huh
even though they want to they just put a
little for sale sticker in like
the corner says correct they could they
could sell it for cash
yeah yeah
but yeah but i think what jake was
asking though is like do you have to
pedal in order to make it move or
is there a throttle where you don't have
to pedal at all uh i think for mid
drive ones where like the motors on the
pedal i think you have to pedal i could
be wrong but i think you have to pedal
the thing is like that's that's the way
that the one that i got for that
video that we did way back in the day
where i liked to work for a week
that's th that one's is assisted power
in the middle
and i think yours was still a hub mode i
think i don't think it was a mid-drive
motor though jake i
but i think no it is you sure yeah okay
okay
yeah yeah it is it's got a little box
and there's nothing on the
the back wheel is just a regular wheel
that would be a min drive okay sure
i rented a mid-drive mountain bike
actually like a month and a half ago
uh-huh
and that was a mid-drive and that was
that had a 250 watt motor for its
mid-drive
and that was able to get me up like
really steep inclines with pretty much
zero effort just making the pedals go
around as long as it was in the lowest
gear
but the bike i'm looking at now is a
1600 watt mid drive
i was there a while back where i was
like really seriously looking into
electric bikes like i really wanted to
have like a nice like full suspension
mountain bike that was able to go 30 to
50 miles on a charge
yeah and like you know thousands of
watts and whatever but then i just kind
of realized
okay i'm looking at thousands of dollars
now like minimum three to five thousand
dollars for these bikes that i'd like to
have and i'm like
or i can just keep doing what i love a
lot already which is one wheeling
yeah that's that's that's an interior
conflict i'm struggling with right now
it's like i might buy an electric
motorcycle oh
there's a couple out there that i really
am intrigued by but i've had to give up
the idea
and pursuit of motorcycles in general i
don't like being around cars
the risk factor is very high yeah even
if you are
perfectly safe it's like you are still
content and this is obviously the
argument around motorcycles as old as
time
it's like you know you're exposed it's
not exactly up to you it could be up to
someone else
whether or not you live or die and
electric motorcycles are quiet they
don't hear you coming
oh yeah especially if you're splitting
traffic like there's been a few times
where like i'll start
changing lanes and realize i hear that
faint sound
of a motorcycle splitting lanes where
they literally drive for all of
you guys who do not live in california
this is a thing here it's not a thing
pretty much anywhere else it's like
fully legal you can drive right down the
middle of lanes and motorcycles do it
all the time
in the middle of the lane you mean in
between lanes
you're driving on the lane and it's
great for traffic if you got stop and go
traffic motorcycles can get to the front
that's nice but like if you're going
highway speeds they'll still split
traffic
and if you start shifting lanes i've
been there where i hear the motorcycle
like wait a minute and i
i double check further back and it's
like they're not right behind me but
they're coming up quick and i have to be
able to swerve back in my lane they go
by
i always like try to give them room too
whenever they go by they always like
they wave
you know they get a little wave yeah but
electric bikes you can't hear them
and so i i'm definitely afraid of
accidentally hitting an electric bicycle
in my car
sorry electric motorcycle in my car on
the highway okay so an electric
motorcycle versus an electric bike
the bikes have the pedals and that that
means they're like
there's some kind of legal there's a lot
of legality aspects there's not too much
difference
between an electric bicycle and electric
motorcycle it's all just
the components involved in the power
output yeah okay and then so but like if
you have pedals on your electric
bike then you don't have to like
register it and get insurance
um i don't know about registration but
the reason why sam has pedals on his
surround bike
is to specifically keep it at a
classification level i think a level two
whereas if he took the pedals off and
put like pegs on it
it would become a level three
certification electric bike
and then that requires a whole different
i don't know what is involved
okay but it involves something okay um
it's one of those things
it doesn't matter to anyone unless
you're actually trying to do it and then
you just do the googling
for all of you are like i don't know it
doesn't matter to you don't worry about
it do the googling you do the google
dance and then you know
what's classification your pets and
pedals are but it's like
like electric bikes with uh pedals are
not allowed to go over a certain speed i
want to say something like 25 miles an
hour
but now electric motorcycles electric
motorcycles are full
motorcycle licensed vehicles those are
teslas and those will go
incredibly fast and they have incredible
acceleration because they've got huge
like
10 000 watt motors on them they've got
it's like being on a jet engine
yeah like the torque and it's that's
see you can't lane split here you can
obviously do it in california
it's a little bit safer i guess um
in texas yeah but just in the country
the idea of
yeah and there's less people on the
roads generally
um so i'm i'm more inclined than i would
have been
but um man just the idea of like riding
on top of this basically you're just
sitting on top of this
motor that has torque that is just
like it the torque is just amazing it's
it like
i mean you guys both have teslas yeah
those
you go i want to be there boom you're
there i have
the slow tesla i literally have the
slowest tesla they make
and it is still stupidly fast yeah yeah
it's funny like it tells would have made
it so like
if somebody's like says like i have a
fast car and it's a gas-powered car it's
just like you don't have the fastest car
you don't yeah and it's also it's like i
don't care about speed i care about
acceleration yeah and
i'm not a fan of noises so i'm not a fan
of loud acceleration you know it's like
look at this thing the control the
control you have is just so amazing and
yeah with the
response time yeah the response the br
the braking that you can have just with
how
far you're pushing down i rarely use my
brake pedal are you saying you're
probably
always doing pedal driving every car
needs to have like the brake built into
the gas pedal
yeah it's great it's like i let up on
the accelerator and i start slowing down
like i just applied the brakes and you
just learned to modulate that to a point
where like i
almost never take my foot off the
accelerator oh well yeah
well like i i take it off to break if i
need to brake really quickly no gas
no brakes no brakes rain drives where he
never touches the brakes
but yeah i mean electric motors have max
torque at
zero speed like torque wears off the
faster you go that's why nose diving is
such a thing on on one wheeling
the faster you go the less torque it has
eventually it doesn't have any torque at
all and you just teeter over
um you know the like the thing about
electric motors that like
doesn't get talked about a bunch people
when people mention it here and there is
like how quiet they are and that's
something
like riding this electric bike a couple
times
it's like you would need to be on a
motorcycle or moped for that kind of
experience
and just realizing that like at will i
can turn on a motor that is completely
silent and then turn it off again
and there's another sport that um i
heard people exploring them and i'm
i haven't checked recently to see how
far they've gotten but uh paragliding we
have the
our paramotor you have the uh the motor
on your back
you know previously you know gonna be
loud and noisy
but if you had one that was battery
powered you can hit that and once you're
up in the air and you're kind of sailing
just
don't hit gas and then it's quiet you
get to enjoy the quiet of flying
with even with the gas pair motors they
turn off they've got like quick starters
on them yeah um and the energy density
isn't quite there yet for the electric
ones i i
this is actually something i
legitimately looked into because i was
thinking about a quarter crew video for
it
and it was just one intense quarter
video yeah yeah
but like people have already like
designed and built battery-powered
versions of these i think peter
streeple even did something like this uh
no
i you know he just actually builds
airplanes um but
yeah paramotoring is something that i've
like i got like really interesting
there's this name there's this guy named
tucker got with a great youtube channel
paramotor and he like he'll go up and
like go down to like mcdonald's and get
drive through and then like
fly up and way back to his house stuff
like that uh
but yeah the electric aspect to that is
the dream right it's like it's super
quiet while you're going and then you
just turn off at a moment's notice it's
like
way more efficient than gas yeah it's
just you you require like literally
these huge battery bricks and you need
like six of them
and then it still gives you like a
little bit of flight time yeah yeah
and they're expensive they're dangerous
uh
you can get home it's a whole thing and
then i don't know that was another thing
that i think i ended up having to kind
of give up just because
yeah can you imagine that would be like
so open
[Laughter]
oh my god i'm literally blanking on his
name right now from uh king of
randomness
died on a paramotor yeah recently like a
year or two ago
yeah yeah and that was that was really
sad he i liked his videos and he had
gotten into paramotoring and
i still don't know if they know exactly
what happened whether it was some sort
of like
shoot malfunction or motor malfunction
or he just kind of came in too hot at
that like i don't know
um but he died and that's it's tragic
yeah
and it's because it's like you know he
was doing something that is inherently
like that level of risk like one
wheeling is risky
but at the same time if something fails
you're not falling ten thousand feet out
of the sky
yeah yeah um you don't have to like land
right right it's not a part where you
have to make contact with the ground
once
more that's so interesting because like
skydiving you know you think of
skydiving as being incredibly dangerous
and yet then you read the stats like
the risk or the danger of actually dying
from skydiving is
so low and that's because the only
people skydiving are incredibly well
trained
and that doesn't change the fact that
you know something could go wrong the
consequences are very very high
exactly the stakes are high where it's
like perhaps not high risk but the
stakes are
very high i saw i saw a chart that broke
down risk into two axes and one was
exact right
the severity of the consequences and the
likelihood of it going wrong
and as long as you're not fulfilling two
of those things it's
it's low to medium risk but once you're
fulfilling two of those things is high
risk so like
if something has a chance of going wrong
a high chance going wrong but this
consequences are really minor
whatever exactly you know who cares
something has severe consequences but
has a very low chance of going wrong say
flying an airplane it's still kind of
whatever i mean
it feels dramatic but still at the other
day
low risk but once you start blending
those two
once you're like i have a highlight of
messing this up and
yeah i might die yeah yeah yeah
it's funny you mentioned that graph a
friend of mine uh literally his work
is based around that graph he's uh
what what is his job title he works at
he's an engineer at
jpl uh his name is bobak ferdowsi he's
actually the the famous mohawk dude from
from nasa if you've ever seen the
curiosity landing he had the mock anyway
with the crazy shirt crazy shirt i don't
know about the shirt oh no that was the
comment later i mean if he's got a
mohawk he probably has a crazy shirt
yeah
yeah no he's really pretty like straight
well-dressed anyway uh
he does like a lot of not necessarily
failure analysis but that
risk analysis type planning for these
mars missions
uh you know he's been at jpl for i don't
know 15 years at this point
uh and so he's not working on mars
anymore i think he's working on
io it doesn't matter one of the moons
right and
a lot of what they do is just kind of
evaluate risk and they specifically use
that graphic
because he shared that graph on twitter
one day and wrote this whole like thread
about it and i found it just super
fascinating
about how you actually calculate and
measure risk
because it's it's risk is something that
feels so intangible
it's like i don't know it's sketchy i
guess but like how bad
sketchy kind of sketchy really sketchy
but it's like it's it's multiple
different places
yeah i have to get insurance like how
sketchy is this guy
but suggested but it's not necessarily a
sketching it could be low sketchiness
but if the stakes are so high like
yeah this is something that will
probably not fail but
once we send it out into space and out
to jupiter there's nothing we can do we
got to make sure it's like quadruple
redundant even though it's a simple
little thing so that's why everything
always gets so over engineered
because they have to be so they call
this the uh the sketch stake analysis
the sketch steak and houses how high are
the stakes
sketch versus steak yeah
your sketch fence is pretty high there i
see it's got the white pickets and uh
it's pretty sketchy yep
yeah um so anyway nico
back to your electric bicycle are you
gonna
where did where did you leave this sort
of analysis you you have a 350 watt
motor now
a 350 watt motor on an e-bike with a
rear drive motor it's cool but it's not
quite the power i want
it's maybe a little light on range but
better than the xr um
so i can't complain that much and i'm
also a little worried about
the bike itself being a little on the
cheap end for the frame once you start
like hitting some hills or like
honestly it's riding in the mountains
that are literally all around l.a well
tangent we're taking another tangent
here real quick i want to talk about
briefly the mountains around l.a
yes everybody thinks of la is a crazy
city and it's dusty and grimy and smells
like pee and all that kind of stuff
um which it does which it does unless
you just tell you're in the mountains
unless you go in the mountains
and here's the thing the mountains are
like literally in the city yeah like
griffith park
is a mountain it's a giant mountain too
it's like it's a big area yeah
and then if you just go a little bit out
there's another huge mountain range
called verdugo or
it's called something else but we call
it i think it's for the purdue mountain
range
verdugo mountain range and there's next
that is the san rafael hills yeah and
just like those little hills and then
right up against all of it
the the angeles forest san bernardino
mountains and the san gabriel mountains
and all that stuff it's it's massive
there are
big big mountains those are very close
to the city create the mojave desert
like those are the mountains that create
the entire southwest united states
desert
wow like i mean that line you know that
goes down yeah yeah
because they stop i guess weather
that's why the los angeles basin is is
different
because all the moisture comes in from
the ocean lands there doesn't go into
the desert
yeah it makes sense yeah uh
but yeah so yeah these mountains they're
pretty great we
hit them all the time um so your bike
let me i'm gonna see if i can paint a
mental picture of what i envision
nico is going through right now he's
liking these bikes they're pretty fun
it's comfortable being stable on a
bicycle and having it propel you
but you want to go up these mountains
and you want to do it with speed
with speed and with i mean
with the blessings of what like the
promise of the technology of bicycle
like the bicycle i've heard is like the
most efficient machine ever made
i don't know if that's true or not but i
like the saying because at the end of
the day as far as something turning
human power into like go power they're
amazing and they're light you know
it is the one wheel is the best thing
since the bicycle
and the bicycle serves purposes the one
wheel can the bicycle is more stable
it's more all-terrain
at a fundamental level the wheel
requires power
in order to go a bicycle is stable with
no power input very true
bicycle also lets you not put 100 of
your attention into writing
there's time like if you're doing
aggressive stuff you can still be like
90 because you got two wheels that are
going to kind of balance you you know
the onewheel if you're doing aggressive
stuff
you got to be in um which is why i do it
though you know it's like i want i like
that feeling i like being locked in
anyways
so i want to be able to do these
mountains i don't want the bike to be
too heavy
and i've been doing research and
electric mountain bikes are
disappointingly
expensive like fred mentioned this in
the beginning they're like
like it starts like five thousand
dollars and goes up from there and it's
like
jesus if you want a decent one i'm not
saying a good one i'm saying a decent
one yeah
they look cool once you get to that
price range all of them look freaking
sweet
too bad i don't care about aesthetics as
much as utility
yeah so one of the best things about la
is it's craigslist ellie has the best
craigslist
i think in the world maybe new york is
like the second best or the
best craigslist since myspace
[Laughter]
you can find anything or anyone on
craigslist in l.a oh yeah i bought my
handpan on craigslist
like that's right your custom built-ins
my first one because i got second
after i i also happened to discover
there's a handgun maker in l.a once
again it's a little you know
same thing it's bringing let's you have
interesting people doing interesting
things
i guess but uh so i looked up on
craigslist you know electric
uh electric mountain bikes of course
there's people that are just reselling
stuff but there's a guy
who makes electric mountain bikes where
he gets a nice electric mountain bike or
he gets a nice mountain bike frame just
a normal frame and the retro fits it
with
the drives he's done like 400 of them at
by this point oh wow um
so you basically can get a really
high-end power
customized mountain bike but you supply
the frame basically it's like
he he has ones that he recommends
because he's like he has all the parts
that can fit them yeah but at the end of
the day it's kind of just a standard
thing but yeah you just it's up to you
how nice the bike do you want to be how
nice you come
how nice of components do you want and
then he'll take it just slap the
mid-drive thing on it and you're good to
go
wow dang okay that seems like a great
idea yeah or great avenue because
uh you were talking about earlier the
the problem with the more affordable
bikes
is that the the the simple components on
them are
dirt cheap yeah in terms of quality like
we're talking like nuts and screws and
a little bit like pale if you're going
down a hill they all fail and that's the
number one thing and so like
uh the experiences i've read about
people who've gone through all this
where they've gone through multiple not
just like
electric bikes but bikes in general it's
like what you're paying for
with an electric or with a nice bike is
the quality parts
that go from the top to bottom like all
of the parts
it might be a good frame it might have
good shock absorbers might have good
handlebars or whatever but like
the you know there might be some problem
with like some other thing that's kind
of critical to making the whole bike run
and if that thing breaks now you got to
fix it and that's the problem that sam's
been facing with the siron bike is that
he keeps having all these
cheap little parts break on him and then
his bike can't he can't use it until he
fixes that one thing and that's happened
half a dozen half a dozen times yeah
like
it's like uh that's the thing about the
one wheel parts
typically don't break on it yeah that's
true
durable and if they do break it's kind
of like oh you just need to re-solder
this connection it's not i
gotta buy another chip or another thing
to drop in or another little
the problems that happen with the
onewheel are like they're really niche
problems like
oh you're trying to like go over too big
of a jump
which almost no one's going to be doing
so you blew out the tire seal or
you tried to you rocked it a little too
hard going down the hill and now like
the little solder pin is coming loose
you got to like re-solder it that's
right
of course i am these are run problems
i guess i'd like to put a question out
there for any listeners who ride
mountain bikes
uh how much of a difference does it make
to have rear suspension
on your bike to anybody who's i've
always heard rear suspension is harder
if you're trying to like go uphill or
just typical riding because it absorbs
some of your energy from every time you
like press down
that will no longer be an issue for me
if there's an electrical motor i mean
yeah question that
i am more of a fan of just having a
softer ride
yeah i mean me too it's just it's
expensive
and a little bit heavier because that's
the other really cool thing it is
heavier yeah like the sewer rod is like
110 pounds
like the cheapo electric mountain bike i
have is only 65 pounds
and if i went this route of having this
guy retrofit a bike it's gonna be like
50 pounds and like
to have that kind of like sprint energy
in a 50-pound bike
like you can zip like taking that out to
like the desert like
mountains and canyons just sitting on
that thing would be sick
there's something that is inherently
safe if you feel safe when you're going
fast on a bike
and it's and it's a strange feeling
because when you're going fast on any
other vehicle a skateboard or one wheel
or whatever
like it feels way more sketch but
there's something about the stability of
a bicycle when you're going
you know over 20 miles an hour let's say
like 25 30. yeah
nothing like dangerously fast but like
this is this is pretty fast
you feel fast yeah yeah um i think it's
because you have a lot of your body
connected to
the vehicle you know you got your hands
on the bars
yeah i wonder how much of it also plays
into the fact that like we all learned
how to ride bikes at a young age and so
it's just like it's so ingrained in our
like brains
how to do bikes yeah maybe
if you think it's like even older than
that though like humans riding horses
and stuff like that
yeah i think it's just fun to mess with
our like inertial computers
yeah we love doing that humans love
doing that
yeah man y'all are making me want to get
a bite
i've already thought about it too so
this is a bike in la is really good to
have yeah
yeah yeah some sort of like non-car
transporter because like
i'm like obviously i'm a huge proponent
of onewheeling but more than that i'm a
huge proponent of
personal electric vehicles yeah i feel
like if everyone really just got on
board with the idea of just like having
an electric bike or something like that
instead of like driving their car the
one and a half miles down to the street
to the grocery store just to pick up a
soda or you know insert whatever and and
then go back
it's like you really don't need to do
that
and it's so much easier on your your
peace of mind to not have to worry about
parking
to not have to work like stuck in
traffic
and there's so many options now yeah
tremendous number of options plus it's
nice just being outside it's nice being
exposed to the outdoors like that
even if it is in the middle of the city
okay nico so now i'm in the market for
an electric bike
what is the real question what was the
price difference to
for the craigslist guy with that could
attach these motors the price difference
of the craigslist guy to like
um like getting a brand name like
american brand electric bike or like a
european brand electric bike bike is
probably about
a thousand dollars to fifteen hundred
dollars okay well maybe even more than
that
like cheaper or like that's for the same
specs
or i guess no not i'm the same specs for
the same specs you're probably looking
like a two thousand dollar gap between
this guy on craigslist and like getting
the thing named brand
so that's a pretty big thing you have to
link that guy to me
definitely considering it yeah i mean
there are areas where diy is always
going to be cheaper but there are areas
where like just buying a product is
going to be
far better for for you and everyone
involved than to do it diy but like
electric bikes is still
definitely in that category of like if
you know what you're doing and you can
get solid parts and it like
the tech the idea behind the technology
is is the simplest thing like literally
when i did that electric bike video it's
like
you have power you have control and you
have
put motor together and you have e-bike
it's like
it's the exact same technology that's an
electric skateboard it's the same exact
technology that's an electric car
it's just different pieces of the same
puzzle yeah yeah i get i
the last thing i would have to say about
the bike thing just to kind of wrap up
your question too
matt and anybody else listening who's
now like man i want to get an e-bike
uh and we're talking i've been talking
about mountain bikes now if you're
just looking for like an electric bike
uh there's actually a ton of
decently priced electric bikes basically
coming out of china because china's
having like a huge
electrical bike revolution right now um
they even had a weird thing where they
were producing way too many and they
were throwing like literally thousands
of them in a landfill
it was a weird time they're like we
can't have yes
i hope that's over i'm pretty sure it's
over i'm pretty sure that's over too at
this point there's a lot of people
importing them into america everybody
slaps some funky
modern brand name on it yeah whatever so
you can get like a real nice like street
cruiser even with like front suspension
for like
you know between probably eight hundred
dollars and fourteen hundred dollars oh
you can get a nice e-bike for 500.
yeah yeah like like decent and what i
was saying like with the commercial
thing
if you're wanting to just get an
affordable e-bike
it's way better just to buy one of these
bikes
because it's going to deliver 85-90
of the experience that you would want to
have yeah with like
zero effort you can go pick up groceries
with it you can get to friends places
with yeah it's like yeah
nico is literally specifically talking
about a very niche desire
kind of like sure you want a rugged
mountain bike
little speed and power and dirt hanging
with the one wheel you know so that's
like
let's go up to the mountains which are
in our backyard
because i know if people appreciate the
mountains in l.a let's go into the
mountains and like play in those trails
you know yeah
yeah but that's definitely a different
ride than
downtown yeah yeah i mean the same thing
with like buying a regular bike
bicycle it's like you can go to a bike
shop and spend five thousand dollars on
this special titanium frame or carbon
fiber frame
that is like wow i can lift it with my
pinky that's crazy which is crazy
it is crazy but i'm also just like not
my thing
yeah i'm like i don't care about nice
bikes i mean i i like the idea of them
but i just i'm not enough of a cyclist
to
see the value in something so expensive
but you can buy a bicycle for like a
hundred bucks
that works about as well as the other
bike it does all the same things
technically if you mark them off on a
checklist
yeah there's that one saying though
there's that one saying which i always
come back to when it comes to things in
your life that you are going to spend a
little bit of extra money on
things that go between you and the
ground yep yeah
damn right shoes mattresses tires
etc bikes bicycles one wheels
yeah where's the lip balm and just to
comment on the simplicity of electric
motors when we were getting really into
building stuff
during the vlog days i i was looking
into
building an electric motor
in
[Music]
yeah because they're so simple you just
need
magnet and you need copper you need the
magnets
it's literally like that's all you need
i mean the the challenging part there
is the winding of the right copper that
there's an actual like intricate
complicated like pattern that you have
to do and then yeah
great you've built a motor but now you
actually need a special control system
to be able to like
fire electrons through it at the precise
like timing to get it to move
right it obviously gets more and more
complex but like just in in the the fear
the theory of it you know is so simple a
brushed motor is simpler
though than uh brush motor is way
simpler but
they don't they have a lot more problems
because a brush motor like
the motor is in a nerf gun for instance
uh it's based off of just pure
electricity you plug it into some power
and the more power you supply it the
faster it goes
because like the actual brush inside of
it makes contact so they wear down over
time a brushless motor cannot wear down
because
there's no contact other than the
bearing bearings wear down over time
yada yada that actually is really
interesting i didn't
know that but it's it's funny because
the the fundamental concept
is the copper when affected by a magnet
wants to move and so as long as you can
keep the copper moving
and connect the moving copper to
something like a like a drive shaft
you know all of a sudden have power
yeah right there's expand upon it
i mean okay jake is for the most part
entirely correct there but it's like
what happens is that when you actually
supply
power to it wow
when you supply power to uh electric
sorry
to the coils in the copper it creates a
magnet magnetic field
and that pushes against the permanent
magnets on the stator
so it's like then it moves and then the
power shifts and it shifts the magnetic
field right
like it turns off and on and off imagine
imagine
uh you're on a pirate ship or some
classic ship right and you've got like
the giant like wheel the horizontal
wheel that everyone's pushing on in a
circle
wait what on a pirate ship i don't know
it's like a horizontal wheel
yeah they have them like imagine like a
wind windmill like something that you
got to
turn and like it's got like all these
sticking out of it
and open latches and stuff yeah the
donkey going in the circle in the middle
so basically you have three teams of
pushers pushing this this
wheel you have like three dudes with the
blue jerseys three dudes with the red
jerseys three dudes with the green
jerseys
and they're all spaced out one after
another bl red blue green red blue green
and uh they can only move when someone
yells their name
and so the red guys are like they hear
red and they're like oh and they push
just for a moment
and then they stop and then someone else
and then someone uh
then the blue guys hear their name blue
and then they push and basically it's
just
those three teams pushing just just
those three teams pushing
for a slight moment one after another
over and over and over again so the
electricity is basically
the copper wires there's like multiple
clumps that are wired up and they each
turn
on and basically yes okay so yeah that's
the idea is that you have
base essentially three different
patterns of coils going around this
stator here and they each get a little
bit of electricity for a moment
they fire up produce a magnetic field
and that magnetic field pushes on the
magnets
of this of the stator which begins to
turn but then as it's
pushing away the other magnet is now
coming in and if they
held onto that power it would the magnet
would then stop
because it's now pushing against that
magnetic field the same one that pushed
the original magnets away
so they turn off and then at the perfect
time
they turn off the next set the green
dudes turn on and they're in the perfect
position to be able to push it again
and so that's what the electronic speed
controllers are doing they're just
firing at thousands of times per second
one after another
to make that thing turn and they're able
to do it so fast that they can modulate
the acceleration of that turning and
whatnot it's super fascinating
that's why the motors inside of those
stators that ren is talking about are
always in like a clover form
okay because each one of those is
different and
and so those create that magnetic field
which is opposing the magnetic field of
the stator
and so it's it's and it's just
constantly doing that but it's just it's
wild to think like it's just using the
power of magnetism
to drive this thing and electromagnetism
it's basically anti-gravity from sci-fi
films except it ended up being on
smaller scale than we thought so use it
in motors
but it is invisible forces acting on
each other yeah we're just
nuts yeah it's wild it's totally wild
we're just harvesting this is no big
deal in everything
one of my favorite things
that's fascinating the coolest thing
about electric motors in my opinion
like obviously it's cool that you can
use some power to make this thing move
like
literally converting electrical energy
to kinetic energy like with no
nothing in between the greatest thing
though is it goes the other way
instantly so like the let's say you want
to capture that energy
like now you're slowing it down but uh
so now you're basically creating these
magnetic fields that
are interacting and that interact and
sorry
the interaction between i'm struggling
with words i'm sorry
my mouth has problems uh the interaction
between those magnetic fields
generates electricity in the wires
basically pushing against those coils
that come through
pushing the electrons yeah as they're
fork because it has its own force in it
at the moment and it's
pushing again exactly and and that's how
you're able to get power out of it and
you basically capture it the same way
you generate it
and but that power can go somewhere and
because it's electricity it's so easy to
basically hand off
that energy they just store it right
back in the battery pack so
that's why you can be in an electric car
up in the mountains with say 200 miles
of range left your battery is like say
two-thirds full
and you get down to the bottom of the
mountain and you have 220 miles of range
you suddenly gained 20 miles because
going down
if you're just to go like you know balls
out and just go
you would die the point
so you slow down by capturing instead of
using your brakes the physical brake
pads you harness that that kinetic
energy and store it into the battery
which has a byproduct of slowing you
down
and giving you more energy which is what
happens when you let off the gas pedal
on a tesla and which is why ren never
touches the brakes
there we go just like the motors and the
magnets
it's pretty amazing man i did not expect
to go onto a whole freaking electric
motor
today what we're working on in cool
projects but we're just going to talk
about
motorcycles no
that's really cool though man yeah we
should talk a little bit about the
attack on titan
yeah and shall we we should yeah we
should also talk about
this upcoming anime yes we should talk
about
the anime drop the anime drop yeah we
should talk
maybe hopefully if we have time a little
bit about cutscenes
as well all right let me talk about the
anime drop real quick and then let's
talk about the attack and titan video
so i know not everybody who listens to
the podcast is into nfts i mean honestly
it's a
it's a small section of our audience
that's into nfts
but the idea of being able to revisit
some of these
things that we have done in the past and
like delve into their worlds again
is really fun like doing that with the
boss town robot for like the
the decade like nfts that we did and now
the next drop we're going to be doing
uh next week is going to be the anime
collection
and we have three anime films anime
baseball anime fidget spinners
and anime self-driving cars which are
arguably some of my most
favorite videos i've ever made but the
thing
about doing an nft like a single edition
nft is that at the end of the day
really only one person gets to
participate in that because it's a
single edition
so we were trying to think of something
that's a little more fun that
like that can be opened up to more
people and so
we decided to do kind of a inspiration
off like pokemon cards and yu-gi-oh
cards and we have
basically a a set of trading cards set
in this universe of anime series
that we're making so we're basically
making nft trading cards
um and we get to go and actually dress
up these like moments and characters as
like actual objects in a trading card
game and stuff it's
so it's been pretty fun and uh i'm
looking forward to people seeing it next
week when we put it together but yeah
it's it's cool it's like going back to
these
videos like i didn't know how many
people died in these videos
a lot of people died in these videos
so we have like three anime yeah we have
like three in memoriam cards
one is for dodger jake's character who
dies on anime baseball
he sacrifices himself so they can win
the game another one the big
the big game the big game yep yeah
another one is for pup pup
the dog that dies an animated
self-driving car
because his car is pushed too hard
oh man jake i just learned today that
that was your dog yeah yeah luna
luna yeah yeah yeah what a funny looking
dog
[Laughter]
well who was the third one was it mike
the third one is z clint's character
who also dies oh you're right but his
soul is turned into a computer
and it's i didn't catch his joke i
forgot about this joke in the end cards
but he starts a family so he's on an
ipad
his girlfriend's still alive they start
a family and their babies on an ipad
and like oh my god that's
so stupid yeah that's right at the end
enemy self-driving cars is such a good
video like yeah that was three months of
my life
yeah it was a very long that was also
right around the time that sam had his
first kid
yeah the whole like everything about it
is like
perfect like frame detail perfect in
that video it's like everything is great
so i'm not even to my own horn like i
didn't actually i didn't shoot any of it
or do the effects on it
but i did write it and like in a way
like i feel really proud of it
also like it's such a absolutely that
was gone when you guys filmed it
and like started doing post-production
that was back for the rest of
post-production but
you know you were handling most of that
uh run yeah vast majority of the work
was sam and i he did
he like uh we got those scans of the
mountains out and we did all that and
then he uh
he knew he was gonna have a kid like any
day so he's just rushing to get like
he basically did all of the the car
animations and the camera work so he
actually placed all the cameras and made
scenes for all that stuff
uh just quick and dirty like oh sure um
and then it was my responsibility over
the following two months to like
turn those into renders and this is
still when i was like kind of a baby at
octane i didn't really know what i was
doing
but they looked so good it took a lot of
work to get him to that point but yeah
it was uh
i'm very proud of that video yeah it
shows anyways it was just
it was nice to revisit it and like look
at these segments and like i've added
down some really cool like trading card
art
one for z one oh there's some legendary
items
oh so d-a-d which is
z's car um
there's a card for that item uh another
one is the the psycho fidget spinner
which is the one with psycho crystals
that of course can drive you insane
uh the junk ball is another one of
course from anime baseball anyways
i could go on but like i told that
reminded me of the dad joke in that
video
what are you broken i'm not broken i'm
dead
that's the flavor text from that card
[Laughter]
yeah peter's just like mocking up some
like really cool like gold
steel like depth like you know
something that feels like you could like
touch it and hold like in your hand
yeah i'm excited about it it's gonna be
it's gonna be sweet um
i'll leave it at that in terms of like
talking about all the little like
tidbits but like being able to delve
back into the lore of those videos like
just the richness of detail that they
have has been really cool
yeah if you get if people listen to this
haven't seen our anime videos
definitely go check them out you'll dig
them so these nfts are dropping next
week wednesday next wednesday which is
the
what day 19th wednesday
may 19th yep two days after the
11th anniversary of corridor really may
17th that's right
oh wow are we the 17th yeah
i know it's the 17th because that is
carmichael's birthday
and it is the norwegian independence
holiday
that's why ren knows that it's the 17th
it was
literally the party lived in north may
17th it's like july 4th
oh you know yeah i lived in norway all
through middle school so it was like
every year may 17th would come around
and everyone would party seriously
vietnam too yeah vietnam that was high
school louisiana
louisiana was great school houston
houston was a little bit of a great
school in high school
it's a little bit i don't like houston
very humid wren how does it feel to have
the attack on titan video
oh my goodness dude i am so happy with
that video but i'm also so happy it's
done
[Laughter]
that was doing it's doing great i am
very pleased with how it's doing it's
been see today's wednesday it went up on
sunday it's already at one and a half
million
views every time the video gets a
million views it's exciting
yeah every time yeah like even now like
with
vfx rs react generally getting a million
views every time like
doesn't matter it's just as exciting now
as it was the first you know it's funny
like i joke around about being
jaded about getting views like oh it
only got a million views
like i'm joking but at the same time
there's a little bit of like okay i was
really hoping for maybe two million
views
uh sometimes but nonetheless you were
absolutely correct it hit a million
views and i'm just like
hell yeah all right i hope it keeps
going
you know what it's weird that we trust
like youtube's you kind of like that's
truly a million people watched it when
it says a million like facebook's you
counter
no no way yeah instagram you're like
a million people stopped at it for three
and a half seconds yeah yeah yeah yeah
that was just
facebook that's what facebook measured
their facebook views as for a while
yeah three seconds yeah youtube's what
10 15.
i think youtube is they have to watch in
15 seconds in
but there might then be a like
percentage of video watch but it almost
doesn't matter because they give you
watch time now yeah yeah no
you can see engagement so you know it's
real or i mean
take views away entirely it's like wow
like you know sixty thousand thumbs up
so a hundred thousand thumbs up so like
you know ten thousand comments
like damn that's like a lot of people
stopped
to talk about this engage with it the
like button is the one that always kind
of makes me take a step back and go
wow like the the attack on titan video
has over 100 000 likes on it
and it's just like literally 100 000
individual youtube accounts
clicked on a button yeah of approval the
entire city of santa barbara clicked
like on it it yeah that it just blows my
mind
it makes it makes all the effort we put
into it feel validated you know it's
like
that's why we work hard on these videos
yeah um yeah that that
whole video was a weird journey in and
of itself i was having like
weird like mental health problems in the
first couple weeks of it and then
finally i was like all right you know
what i'm getting my groove
snap and break my collarbone and now i'm
having to deal with this and all the
weird problems that came from that um oh
snap you actually handled the uh broken
collarbone pretty in stride
yeah i was thinking you really did yeah
i'm is there
like are breaking bones kind of routine
to you at this point no okay it used to
be
you seemed to handle it like it was
broken it uh
you know i'm honestly surprised myself
uh it's been a very long time since i
i've broken a lot of bones but
i used to like back when i was a kid i
broke enough bones that the hospital had
to like
interview me separately from my parents
they would do bone tests to make sure
that like i didn't have like
fragile bones apparently my my bones are
100 normal
uh apparently those are 100 metal
uh you know they interviewed me to like
like do parents hit you
i'm like no like those kind of questions
it's so long ago that i
only when i barely remember like the
interactions it was just one of those
things where it's like
the doctor come in like to cut the cast
off like he started giving me
experimental casts like i was one of the
first people in all of louisiana to
receive a waterproof cast
and it was white they didn't have colors
at the time and so my mom painted it
this is over the summer she painted it
as like an american flag
and uh when they cut it they cut it down
like here and then around the backside
and they put it up on display in in the
hospital room and it was there for years
they had a whole they had a whole suit
of armor made out of casts that was just
fine
now it's important to know most of the
bones i broke were usually in my wrist
because i was very very cl not clumsy is
not
quite the right word i was very
overactive and highly energetic
and impulsive and so i'd fall down a lot
and when i would fall i would
put my arm out and lock it in place and
something's got to give in those
situations usually it'd be a bone in my
wrist would just kind of crack sometimes
the entirety of my arm would fold
backwards uh i had these scars here on
my arm from when they had to put some
plates into my arm for that
plates i lost them i used to have i had
them all through college i don't know
where they are now i i'm pretty sure i
still have them somewhere i just can't
find them
um they're not in your body anymore no
no they had to remove them because i was
a kid i was still growing they have to
remove the plates so
i had i underwent surgery to have them
put in then like eight weeks later i
underwent surgery to have him take him
out oh wow
i had like i i bent my leg as a when i
was like
five or six uh i was young enough that
the bones were still worse than breaking
it
it was my it was my my shin bone here my
left shin bone
i i jumped and landed uh i won't go into
detail of who i landed on but i
basically like
bent my it was my sister i bit my leg
around her face
wrestling move no i jumped off monkey
bars it was this it was we had monkeys
what happened to her she was fine
she was totally fine but like it was
enough that like it bent
my foot my parents were having like this
going away party for one of their
co-workers and
the whole party very awkwardly uh and it
was like we've always caught like a
broken leg because it looks broken and
freaking out it's at an angle
uh but apparently i was young enough
that it didn't actually crack or break
so the doctor gave my parents two
options
we can undergo surgery give them uh
you know all the what do you call this
stuff they make you go to sleep for uh
anesthetics
yeah anesthesia which is dangerous for
someone his age i was like five
uh it's a risky operation but we'd be
able to fix it and be fine
or i could bend his leg over my leg
right now and
fix it right now bend it
no they bent it i know which one
you poor person i screamed so
loud i remember the details of this room
i was five and yet
this room still stands out in my memory
the doctor was like all right ready
three
over his thigh like right here just like
and apparently
my mom remembers this more than me uh
this i i wailed
so hard that they both instantly
regretted their decision
but that being said i think in the end
it worked out because i only had to have
a cast on for like a couple months and
it was like not a big deal we didn't
have
as it was i was already maxing out my
parents healthcare coverage
i was gonna say that man you were like a
healthcare nightmare it was a problem
when i was a kid
but then at around the age of 11 or 12 i
just stopped breaking things
i think i learned how to control my
impulsivity a little bit
and uh suddenly i stopped having
problems it only took a decade
yeah yeah so over the course of the
following 10 20 years i didn't really uh
break much there are a few times like
for instance i know now that i broke my
kneecap when we were in
vegas for nab because i drunkenly tried
to jump over
a dividing line you know like those
those thick
velvet lines that they have outside of
clubs i was in the middle of a uh
of a casino and i just tried i was i was
i was pretty drunk
yeah i apologize and i tried to just hop
over because there's nothing on the
other side and i needed to go down this
hallway so i was like i hopped over it
but my foot caught it
and i ended up going up and then landing
on my kneecap
and i remember complaining the entire
drive home this is like nab 2018 i think
i
i complained the entire ride home i was
like guys my knee hurts and everyone was
like
shoot up we were dead no you were not we
weren't that many no
i was i was definitely exaggerating that
you were not mean at all but it was just
i definitely got the feeling like okay i
guess i should stop mentioning this
it really hurts and like months go by
like it wasn't actually ever broken but
then a friend of mine who is a doctor
i had him check it out and he's like
feeling my kneecap here and uh he's like
all right this ridge
that's what's called a bone spur
basically your your kneecap cracked
and like bone fluid seeped out and
started forming new bone material
so i have like this like little rage
across my kneecap now it's totally fine
it never hurts it's it's not a thing but
well huh
yeah wow anyway so that leads to this
clavicle
ah um during attacking titan you're an
attack on titan
i so i went back to the doctor last week
and he was very happy with the progress
i'm making the the bone was initially
like overlapping a little bit
and when you say happy like do you like
clap his hands and smile or like what
he had a lot of relief he was like i'm
so glad we made that decision that was
the right call he just kept saying over
and over that was the right call
the call he's referring to is not having
surgery the whole point of coming back
the second time was to
like you know check up to maybe we do
need to still have surgery but
uh all the shards that were there are
starting to ossify and shrink a little
bit there's
uh the bone had stretched out so now the
bone is actually at length what does
that
mean it hardens up it's it's like
calcifying is that it's to make
something hard it's like overly hardened
gotcha i guess okay brutalized i don't
know i'm not exactly sure the specific
definition
wait ossify means to turn into bone or
bone tissue
okay so it's even more related to bones
than i thought
the first time i ever heard the term
ossified bones it was when i was reading
all of the lore
around the spartans from halo comes from
the last halo street
bonus book from halsey
did you look that up i've just looked it
up oh anyway yeah
the spartans had extra hard bones like
ossified bones
yeah so good i read the books man i knew
all that [ __ ] oh yeah
like osteoporosis yeah
yeah that makes sense um yeah so anyway
uh it's i mean there's not really much
to it he was glad that i don't need
surgery uh
uh there the bones have stretched out so
now they're at length they're still like
crooked but they're
at length they're not overlapping each
other um and so
yeah that first seven days were awful
constant pain
uh anytime it got cold was the worst
cause i'd start shivering and shivering
is basically just uncontrolled muscle
spasms
and so every time any of these muscles
would activate they would pull on my
collarbone it would just be tremendously
painful
uh after about a week it was about seven
days or so
two days over the course of the
following two days i rapidly improved
far less pain far more mobility i can do
crap like this strength back i could lit
i could lift a fork to my mouth
and that was because the bone was
actually starting to regrow just a
little bit imagine like two sticky pads
on the end of sticks just kind of
touching each other
just enough that like if you're to pull
on it sideways a little bit
it doesn't actually budge but not
grown enough that if i was to pull a one
wheel plug
out of a one wheel accidentally
uh with the wrong arm you get blinding
pain oh yeah jake we fixed your onewheel
by the way
you did you had to break your re-break
your clavicle to do it
i think i might have actually kind of
damaged my clavicle a little bit in the
process
and now by the way from our perspective
we were upstairs
and we heard a s a piercing scream
coming from that and at first me and
dean looked at each other and were like
smash is it smash bros is that what's
going on
and then nico comes out and then with
like there's like a herd of us that
comes out to check and we
we're like we hear like red and couple
other people down there and we're just
like oh [ __ ] no
nico's like i realized it was red just
in searing pain
yeah uh i have a third-party uh charger
for the one wheel
it had a bad plug but it didn't occur to
me that it would ever actually
weld to the plugs inside the onewheel
which we think is what happened to your
board jake
uh which is why we couldn't remove it we
thought maybe uh you and i when we're
trying to remove it we thought maybe the
little
the springy thing on the charger plug
was like stuck that was fine it was
actually like
welded it's your board works totally
fine now by the way it's it's all good
i've double checked it
but i tried something different where i
put some downward force on it and then
pulled
i just happened to be holding it with my
right hand at the time
and i just i wasn't thinking i was like
try i had it on both hands but it just
like
and my hand went backwards and torqued
on my collarbone so hard
i literally came two minutes later and
it was uh
natalie and christian were there and
jordan had come down the stairs i was
like oh man
oh that would have been embarrassing if
other people saw me in this state
man i'm glad it's just you three the
cool opposite
walked in there stopped in the balcony
looked at ren
looked at anytime
i have no recollection of anyone else
showing up there i just remember just
blinding pain
it's it's been a thing so every now and
then i'll have like a moment of like oh
that hurt a lot
yeah it goes away pretty quickly
throughout the producing of
attack on titan there would just be
moments where we'd be talking about
a shot or about a concept and he would
just just like sit there for a second
like okay give him a little bit of air
that was that was a constant thing that
happened you did give us a heads up
though
like just let you guys know at some
point i might just
loudly yelp yep and jake wrote a
wonderful song
a wonderful song it's called the song
yeah yeah uh but i mean
i don't know i feel like i recovered
fairly well i say recovered as if it's
in the past no it's still very much so
active it has been
see today's wednesday it'll be three
weeks from tomorrow
that i actually had the accident so i'm
three weeks into this and i i feel fine
enough that i can like move around
fairly easily your bones are sticking
together a little bit right now i think
they're stuck enough that i can i can do
stuff but i still can't like
i can't wash my hair for instance oh man
i can't like there are times where i
like i'll lift a bottle of water with my
right arm and i can't quite get it to my
mouth
a little stuff like that also i still
have a broken shoulder in two spots
i have a chip and a break in my shoulder
that is completely separate from my
bone and the pain from that is starting
to return
oh over the last week or so that's been
hurting me every now and then because i
get more motion
back and so now when i reach certain
areas i hurt my shoulder
and that manifest is a very different
way the clavicle it's
instantaneous pain very sharp very quick
but almost just as quick as gone
it's like it's like getting poked with a
needle or something just for like a
moment
but the moment you take it away it's
like okay the pain is gone whereas the
shoulder i'll like tweak it a little bit
i'm like oh okay here we go no pain yet
but over the course of five seconds it
ramps up until i'm like oh
that hurts a lot and it sits there and
then it slowly goes down again
and i think that's because i actually
have a torn labrum it's the fleshy stuff
and
i don't know man i have to i still have
to have surgery on that
yeah and i have to wait until this is
healed before i can do that
so i'm like man how often should i one
wheel now
should i limit it to 30 times a week i
don't know you should wear
shoulder pads dude you should wear like
a football
players dude you need to wear a whole
suit of armor you're not one-wheeling
right
i'm not i did i take that back i did get
one one wheel shot for the video
uh two weeks ago um it was the shot
where like the bone
lands on the ground and starts growing
until it snaps in half that's like
across the street from my house and so
like
i was like i need to get the shot yeah
do it for the show if i'm really careful
i can get on a onewheel and it'll be
okay
rarely ever you know it's like yeah it's
totally fine it's like
the biggest risk from one wheeling comes
when you stop really
paying like 100 attention so like i was
very hyper aware very hyper
uh conscious of the fact that i should
not be on a one wheel
but i did it anyway and i got the shot
and it was worth it
from the sketch to stake scale sketch
was low stakes are high but
stakes were medium high sketch pretty
low though exactly
exactly it was a risk i was willing to
take yeah i'll put it down
start referring to the stakes in terms
of how well you cook a steak
yeah medium medium to medium and sketch
is the chord the quality of the cut
it's like where's that stick from it's
pretty good it sketches the quality of
the cut and the
the risk of it and the consequence is
like uh the more the more well done it
is the less consequence
so so me doing something that's both
risky
and severe consequences would be like
i'm going to take out this tenderloin
and get it real real rare like yeah
really
a rare tenderloin would be a rare
skirmish or something a
rare skirt steak
all right i don't know how well that yes
i so i realize
that i've been talking a lot about like
my my bone history which is something
i've talked about before
i apologize for all you guys who are
rolling your eyes like all right here we
go again
runs flexible bones
but yeah no i i think the attack on
titan video went well
uh i think the the oh yeah i stopped
taking painkillers about a week after
the break it was about seven days after
because i had to drive to work the next
day jenna was gonna be working so i
didn't want to take an uber
and i was like i think i'm well enough i
don't need to take these pain meds
anymore so i stopped taking them
and i was able to drive because you're
not supposed to drive when you're on
payments um
specifically i think i was on percocet
anybody who watched the
podcast from two weeks ago sees why
you're not supposed to drive them
this is very like a loophole it's like
probably good you stopped taking them
because
i about the addiction aspect of things
i'm like
if you take them longer than like 10
days like it's you
start setting it like oh i kind of want
them and it's not it's not good
oh yeah yeah yep uh yeah uh where was i
going with that the biggest problem i've
had are just these
really intense knots that i'm getting on
my shoulder blade now and i don't know
if it's from
being at a desk in a certain posture but
they're really bad knots like they
they're pinching these nerves that are
going up my neck and i've tried a whole
bunch of things to get rid of them
i have like this little like freaking
massage stick i have a massage like
theragun type deal i have a
a tennis ball that i lean against on the
wall uh
heat pads i'm trying a whole bunch of
stuff they all work relatively well
but the break i had over the weekend
helped a lot don't have the knots
anymore
uh where was i going to attack on titan
yeah yeah
yeah sorry it's all about me am i right
i mean matt this was a this is the first
time i legitimately had someone else
help so much with the edit and you you
came too
and like really a lot brought a lot of
uh your own personal spice to the video
yeah
and it was a freaking blast man i had a
fun time working on this video it was a
good video
um yeah and you mentioned uh in the
behind the scenes the uh keep moving
forward video that daniel made which is
a great video if you're on the website
definitely check that one out
um you mentioned a video that just went
out oh my god that's so funny i just
watched that earlier
i have not watched that yet it's so
funny uh but you mentioned
that you have to like find the balance
between adding your own spice but not
going too far
because it's just going to be waste of
time anyway i'm wondering if maybe next
time
open the gate dude i can open the gate
like i'm wondering if like next time
like i wonder
like obviously we still i still gotta
keep like some of that structure
uh in place but like if you have an idea
for like uh like a zesty like
zesty garbage damn a little earlier in
the process like in the
maybe not have a broken bone in the
middle don't have a broken bone first of
all
and then also like yeah i know you are
you just kind of like
you know get your horse blinders on and
really you know sit down and write all
by yourself but
having someone else there at least to
review some of those yeah
yeah it's a thing i'm kind of it's like
for as much pride as i take into being
flexible about what i do
i'm still very much so stubbornly uh
resistant to to
my ways you know it's like uh having you
film all the little
handwriting things like i've always done
that as the final step because i have
the context of the entire video
here like all right this is everything
that's going to be there what are all
the bits that need to be illustrated
with
with numbers or words or some sort of
that thing
uh but this time we started that way
sooner in the process
and i was not happy about having to do
that way sooner in the process but
ultimately i'm very happy we did
sure you don't have to scramble to do
that at the left side exactly exactly
you imagine having to do that on friday
or on saturday or sunday good morning
you know we finished friday and i was
like guys
this is great we are done like we were
done on time on a friday yeah and then i
ended up staying until midnight on that
friday trying to finish this shot and
and
a few other things i was like i'm done
tonight so i i ended up working
saturday through parsec on my home
computer it was very casual it was the
chillest work day i've ever had just
casually working
and then like dinner comes around i'm
still not done with the final titan shot
and it's like 8 p.m and i'm like okay i
think i got
i think i'll be done with this shot in
another like one or two hours there's
not too much left to do with this shot
seven hours later it is four in the
morning
four or five in the morning and i'm now
finishing the vfx shot
and i'm like happy with the vfx shot and
now i've got to drop it into the edit
and sound design it
make it work with the music and a couple
other things i'd forgotten to tidy up in
the in the in the whole video because i
a lot of saturday was spent like
uh like uh levellating audio and stuff
like that
it was fine i got the video uploaded at
like 6 a.m
three hours before the launch and it was
like
you know i tried really hard to not have
to do this this time i tried really hard
to make sure that this wasn't a thing
and i thought i was on top of schedule
every single day like i was actually
really proud of being on top of the
schedule
and inevitably i still ended up having
to do extra stuff just do it
uh anyway it's one of those things that
i actually ironically didn't mind in the
least because
this was a passion project it was like i
would much rather put in the extra time
to make it at least
what it was trying to be rather than
like you know what
this is like kind of a critical shot of
the entire video but yeah
cut it i already cut shots from the
fight scene we had like a whole bunch of
extra shots that i had filmed i actually
went back
and got pickups i filmed over the
weekend later to get pickups for these
extra shots
that i pretty much immediately turned
around was like i'm cutting them
we don't have time to do all these shots
i'm going to cut them right now this
still works without them
well you know me and you know speaking
for myself but also for the other
millions of people who watched it
million and a half people
uh the amount of passion you guys put
into it really shows and it's a really
fun video to watch
so i'm glad you guys put i feel like
that stuff really pays off when you
really like
the project it does you know i feel like
we're in the middle of youtube changing
again
you know remember how it like changed
way back in the day from views to watch
time and that was when we saw the rise
of all the the let's play makers and
whatnot
and then like it was it changed again
since then uh when it went to more like
audience engagement rather than watch
time for like driving the algorithm i
think
now like and we've been in it for the
last year or two i feel
like it's been more like youtube's uh
rewarding higher quality content more
than they used to
that's why you see mark robert uploading
a video once a month and it gets 30
million views
granted that's because mark robert is a
unique exception because he's brilliant
in everything he does but like
we're starting to see more of that we're
starting to see more rewards can be
marked
by that can be marked very closely by
the change in the in the
on the from the youtube product team
when they went from view based
reward to then watch time based reward
to now what they call viewer
satisfaction which is what they started
about two years ago this is a
combination of all
of of it's a combination of time
interaction
uh comments sharing like how
how well you are using and consuming
those videos as part of your overall
experience on the site
yeah so it's a lot more complex and
that's what that's the overall term for
it that they use now
so i feel like it's very evident when
viewers watch one of these kind of
videos it's like oh wow you put a lot of
effort and time into this this is not a
a typical video that we see
week to week and i think the audience
response
to that is recognized by the youtube
algorithm uh the satisfaction
that we've talked about and and i think
that's what helps drive the success of
those those
videos because it's like trying to make
these videos like two three years ago is
what we were going through with quarter
back in the day like five four or five
years ago it's like
we put like a month-long effort into
this one video
and we're like this video is awesome
we're so proud of we put it up and it's
like
it's 300 000 views it's like cool
i mean pop off to be fair there's an
element of that this is like this is the
old old school youtube in me talking
it's like
you get the views you deserve sure sure
because
you just you get you you deserve kid
that middle ground when youtube was was
all in on the watch time things this is
like when we that was why we started the
vlogs
it was like we can't just keep producing
three to six minutes a month of content
we have to have some sort of way
to continue pumping out more time and
that was literally how the vlog was born
and to be fair now like the format that
of corridor back then is like what would
work on tick tock or instagram these
days yeah
um well not maybe kinda it's like we
were a little bit longer form than like
the tik tok form
and we're like a little short form for
youtube it was weird
yeah but i really liked being able to do
all those cool concepts
yeah but you know what everybody's like
man is a quarter channel dead
what's happening on the corridor channel
you guys haven't uploaded anything since
uh
i guess well about that guess what
we got a quarter video coming out like
two or three days i don't know what day
this
podcast saturday yeah it's coming out
saturday oh yeah we can tell everybody
listening it's coming that we have a
new video coming out on saturday it's
called the cut scene
i mean name subject to change because
that often happens that's right
the 15th the i don't know
either way sam has been cranking along
on this
really cool uh piece that's all done
inside of unreal so the whole thing is
animated
um it's been an exploration into the
world of like a little bit like cartoons
i mean this it's not kind of a
hand-drawn cartoon but it is fully
animated
so it's almost it's kind of a cartoon in
a way uh it all takes place within a
video game
and it's really interesting to watch
like it
it hits different than like a live
action video you know interesting
i've been specifically avoiding i wasn't
involved in the early uh
concept of it and then the production of
it and like sam wanted to bring a couple
of people into like you know review it
and give some notes and kind of just see
the progress of it
and i like like him and i locked eyes
and i was like
i'm not going to watch he's like i'm
going to satisfy you so well on friday
your viewership is going to be so
satisfactory so
just wait the first time i see this will
be kind of the like the final product
yeah and you know so the big under
arcing thing here i think this is not
us just trying to make a story out of
things like this is an actual corridor
thing
you know sam has a certain quality a
threshold of quality he needs to hit
for him to be able to go out and do
local zero and you know we really really
hold ourselves to accomplishing the
things that we said we would do on the
website you know the green light shows
we're gonna we're
doing them you know it's not like
kickstarter where you can decide whether
or not you want to after the fact
that you can just take money and believe
yeah
um so you know local zero which
we have a story that i think we're all
really jiving on we want to do it
justice and
if sam can't get the technology to work
like we're not we
we're not gonna do it until we can get
the technology working and that means
you know having characters that
legitimately convey motion and having
workflows that legitimately work and not
having
visual errors just blatantly in the
center of your screen
if a character glitches out you you
can't have that like you need to set a
you know a threshold of quality for
yourself
um and up until this point
sam hasn't felt like we've gotten there
like the closest thing we got was the
handsome squidward video and then that's
like a super compact
like approach and even then it didn't
actually fully work like we managed to
hide the problems really well
yeah and you get like a bit of that that
like jankiness sometimes when you're
looking at like a human face that is
just like very inherently uh
uh limited you know like the the what
was it the video game characters react
video
like sam's been like steadily
experimenting non-stop with this tech
for like well over a year at this point
he's like a two-year endeavor now
yeah uh he's just slowly learning a lot
more slowly getting a lot better just
constantly like
you know he's doing it right you know
he's he's learning in
in experimenting through this whole time
but he has
these goal posts that are projects that
he's completing and you learn from those
projects that's one of the most valuable
things about the corridor crew channel
to like at least to me as an
artist as a person is it gives us it
gives me goal posts it gives sam go a
post it gives you all of us goal posts
you know it's when we're making a
quarter crew video it doesn't have to be
a year's worth of effort into one video
you can take chapters of this effort and
in themselves there are stories and put
those out as a quarter group
dude i feel cabin fever if i'm trying to
work on the same project for too long
like that anime self-driving cars video
that three months by the end of it i
hated it
everything about it i wanted to not ever
touch another cg car again in my
life and you haven't
actually but like my point was that like
i was just like i'm so ready to work on
anything else please no i feel that too
it's weird i'm we're a little spoiled by
like the ability to just
have variety in our lives i know right
yeah anyways
uh i'm diverging from what i'm trying to
get to here which is
ladies and gentlemen sam's finally done
it he's done it he's hitting the quality
threshold really
after this we can make local zero this
uh i knew nothing about this video very
little about it before watching it today
and uh it's kind of like uh insane it's
kind of insanely cool
um i don't know much about it i've seen
like every now and then sam will post
like a little video clip on discord and
just kind of like showing it and like
i'll check that every now and then like
what the heck like
it's it's about what the hell is that
boy doing it's a cut scene video it's
about video game cut scenes
that's all i'll say about it that's
about the extent of what i know
yeah and how the rules change yeah
interesting now this was acted out by
you and sam right you guys spent a day
in those mocap suits and just like
did all the the choreography voice
acting so that's all in there too
cool choreography
like you know well yeah there's it's
nice like when you're doing an animation
it's fun because you get to boil down
like the true essence of like
storytelling in a way and it's live
action has
great things about storytelling too like
there's a certain way you capture
performances
and photography and live action that's
unparalleled in any other medium
um but like in terms of doing the the
motion capture and the voice acting
it's it's very much about making sure
you have clear and clean
communication of what you're trying to
do in the story and then
when you're doing like multiple takes
there's no continuity to worry about
like you you do a take until you feel
like you get it
and then that take is saved in the
computer and that's the take you use and
you can film it from one angle another
angle another angle and
you can get as much coverage of that
take as you want and you know when you
get into the edit
that you'll never have to cut around
continuity or angles or lines or weird
things like that because every shot is
basically a perfect shot
of this yeah perfect you know ideally
perfect performance that you picked out
yeah the other thing that like from
doing these other projects
it's informed sam on this and it's also
helped me wrap my head around like what
works in terms of filmmaking
i mean i'm not a pro by any means but
like what i'm figuring out is that
unless you want to go real hard to the
world animation which we actually don't
we want to make sure we're
able to deliver on like uh getting
content out there where that matches the
pace that we can write stories
um you know you need a system that works
and what adult swim
has done a lot for their cartoons was
cartoons which is basically like two or
three people riffing with each other
almost doing like semi-scripted improv
theater
and then like taking just the cheapest
approach to animating that you know like
you know
any of the like the space ghost coast to
coast or like sea labs
like the most like rudimentary like
they're literally just recutting other
people's animation
like lip sync it's basically a podcast
with like recut
realizing that like that's the essence
that we needed to bring to
to virtual production stuff for it to be
compelling
and like work is i think something that
we sam really tried to realize with uh
the cutscene you know it's me and sam
acting with each other
dynamically riffing and improving and
basically taking a little bit of the
scripted stuff and bringing a little bit
of our experience
like filming on the chord or crew
channel where you're sometimes running a
bit and kind of like feeling
trying to hit jokes yeah yeah and it
worked like it totally does there's
vibrancy to the characters you know
which uh
if we pursue pursued more in the future
i feel like ideally we bring in voice
actors who can
find that same vibe but it was really
fun yeah
it's exciting i it's like i remember you
had your hesitations
uh late last year about uh unreal as a
technology about whether it's something
we should like
yeah whether it's worth putting effort
into like
and i and i i feel like you've come
around and you're like you see it's
potential now with what we can do
i think i i think i see this potential
but i think i've put my finger more on
like what it's
good for doing okay sure yeah because
there's that question like man should i
be like writing stories like filming and
unreal should we like really be
investing in this or like should i be
like
going back to live action because we
haven't really shot any live action
stuff because of the pandemic that's
that's why the corridor channel's been
so quiet literally the last quarter
video we made was the domino's video
yeah and that was basically pretty sure
it was right yeah
well that's the last one we shot but
after that one you monster released
oh that's and tactical three loads
released right which were so yeah we
actually had a pretty good last year it
just ended in august we had you know
dominoes we had tactical three loads we
had
you monster i think we had uh the clay
face like ghost hunters video as well
that was the beginning of the video the
beginning of the year yeah yeah so
i mean we had some videos come out but
the pandemic definitely slowed things
down
but yeah like thinking about like how do
i want to create
films and videos coming going forwards
like i've realized that unreal is not
the place to go if you want to do crazy
action
you know unreal is not the place to go
if you want to do like sam says
precision filmmaking
where it's like you know a guy holds a
katana up to another guy's neck
um unreal is the place to go if you want
like
character based theater against crazy
backgrounds
unreal's place to go for crazy costumes
you know it's
crazy environments it's having an
interesting dialogue scene
that ideally is flavored up by
spontaneity and improv yeah in a crazy
setting with crazy looking characters
um but at the end of the day it's really
just your voice acting that's going to
drive the story and the rest
is just cool things to look at i mean i
think of like red versus blue for
instance yeah one of my one of my
favorite all-time shows of
like all time uh granted you know i'm
talking about like my high school days
here
uh the first several seasons it was like
literally the funniest stuff and really
when it came what it came down to is
like
it was just really good writing really
good banter between
these voice actors who already have a
rapport but the backdrop was a halo
multiplayer map
yeah like literally just halo with oh
you point the gun down far enough the
heads look up and now
if you bring the gun up a little bit the
head goes down so if you bob it back and
forth like it looks like they're talking
like that they made an entire they're on
like season
18 now i think of red versus blue
they're still going
maybe it's a higher like 100 multi 100
person company
yeah no that was exactly rooster teeth
has become a huge
uh entertainment like thing
uh and it has evolved a lot over the
years but
it all started with red versus blue it
all started with just some dudes
reading a very good script and just
throwing a random arbitrary background
it just happens to be halo
yeah uh but because it was halo they
could shoot each other with tanks they
could stand in these
weird backdrops it was cheap filmmaking
because it was just there
yeah our minds just want an image to
like give us grounding
and help us lay the framework for our
imagination as the story is being told
you know
yeah okay a film is about like looking
at a person going i wonder what they
would be feeling right now what would i
be feeling if i was in their shoes in
this situation i would be feeling this
maybe they're feeling this like
it's the same thing it's still about
trigging your imagination and like when
you get into cartoons it becomes even
more like
symbol based like you know happy face
it's like okay that character's feeling
happy i wonder if i would feel happy
like you know it's like you're just
trying to you're just trying to get
people to put their imagination in this
world
and you're giving them as much structure
as they need to do that like even just
like ai generated images with their like
dream like
wackiness and surrealist look like if
you still if you wrote a book and you
just stuck one of those on every page
that kind of vibed with like what you're
reading
it's like even if it's just abstract
colors and shapes you'd be like yeah
dude i'm feeling this like
it's like it's it's the closest like
soundtrack music like background
orchestrated music like movies is
literally that
it's abstracted sounds that trigger
emotions
to help you just like feel and vibe with
where things are going it's just giving
you construction like you should feel
sad
yeah this is a sad moment you should
feel sad okay now this is an exciting
moment you should feel excited you're
like
yeah okay i'm feeling excited i would
definitely feel excited if i was in this
situation
that's that's a fascinating comparison i
hadn't considered that yeah it's kind of
like boiling down just the essence of
emotion and performance
yeah in in this like face cap and mocap
yeah
it's just all about building structure
it's weird though it's like
because you can go really janky with it
but what's the jankiness that's okay and
what's the jankiness that distracts you
and pulls you out you know it's like
it's like the rules of the world like
these
these characters are in a video game
like they're not photo real at all you
know you're not
looking at a person their emotions are a
little wacky but there are emotions and
so it's more like
the way i'm saying it is like you know
the character needs to be happy at the
right time
but the happiness can have the fidelity
of a sharpie marker drawn on happy face
like
it doesn't matter how good the happy
face looks it matters if it's the right
time for the happy face right
yeah okay yeah it's like cutscenes is
the perfect application for
unreal though yeah because it is a game
engine it isn't and we're making a cut
scene like it's a cut scene
yeah so it because of that it's like see
for
in a weird way it's grounded to that
world like it's very
it's hard to say like something is
grounded when it's a completely you know
computer-generated world but like
it is because it's you know it's you're
immersed in in a world that you're
familiar with
which is a cutscene yeah and now let's
take it and
spend it like little serendipitous
things and local zero works the same way
like it also ha play takes place in a
video game
and in a futuristic video game and like
the idea that like maybe we'll have a
character that's literally just
not like you don't wear a mocap suit but
you just use her a controller and the
person being doing voice acting and they
just play the character
literally by moving a character on
screen with basic third person controls
because that person in real life hasn't
bought the fancy vr suit yet you know
so you have like the crazy mocap
characters and you have the one guy
who's still just doing like basic third
person like you know
yeah yeah but you still have in real
life you have an actor doing it
you know when they have their microphone
and you have people in mocap suits and
they're just watching the screen and
interacting with their character using
your controller sure you can just all
the different tiers of like
video game aesthetic it buys you that
freedom but yeah
i'm really psyched for local zero like
part of me is like oh man we should like
take this out there and like pitch it
it's like no
no no no just make it just make it if
it's good people will dig it
and they can grow from there if people
want more yeah you can always you can
always expand upon the first
iteration of it yep easily just go out
there and make it
we say it a lot so we gotta practice
what we preach yeah
so cutscenes is coming out this weekend
local zero
is coming out later
yeah there is no date on local zero yet
no yeah
but it it i mean we're working on it
like
what's the general part of working on it
yeah fair enough that is true that is
true i i i believe that
what's the general uh
hope for releasing son of a dungeon
timing-wise yeah um
i i think august
august okay here's where we're
[Music]
disappoint people but we also don't want
to take forever because then you know
the longer we take to get these shows
out it's the longer
until we can get another show out you
know yeah what i told carmichael is
if it comes out in october we need to be
asking ourselves with
specificity why is this happening
yeah so it's i feel like it's moving
along pretty well so far
yeah it keeps moving yeah jake why don't
you tell like for the people listening
just tell us where are we and what are
we doing with it
we've gone through every episode almost
cut now there's one more no all the
episodes have been at least well
i'm on four and yeah matt's on four and
he's close and that
nat's on six and after that that's first
draft on all
well episodes eight one-hour episodes
right yeah eight
some hour episodes not necessarily one
hour somewhere longer than an hour well
i mean think about it we filmed two
episodes a day for eight hours a day
it's like each episode has four hours of
content behind them
it's gonna be somewhere between eight
and nine hours of content
total as a finished product this is a
big deal
this is the biggest thing we've ever
done in terms of like run time
and and quality i do know nat has made a
pass on the final two episodes at the
very least
but yeah there's a very there's a big
difference between like a pass on
something and
actually like a fine edit so so now
after that then carmichael goes in
he's working on draft two of
things matt and natalie will probably
also go in and work on draft two
and then we lay in all the markers for
all the effects
and then we go okay is this where we
want to have our effect scenes
and then we find gets final sign off on
that then that goes into
exporting all those scenes for the
actual filming of the green screen
photography
then you have to take all that green
screen photography
and now comp it all into eight to nine
hours
of content so each door we walk through
it's like
it's like we're crossing giant
mountainous valleys
you know yeah and there's only like two
left but they're huge
and you know start walking
yeah we're just we're just walking man
yeah we're getting there
yeah and we don't exactly know how that
workflow's gonna go once we start like
having to do the live action stuff we
might try to shoot down a light stage
really yeah that might be the perfect
application i think it would be the
perfect application
for some of the shots yes some of the
shots yeah well the idea is that we are
able to photo scan the entire
uh set whatever what do you call the
stage
the map the you know the table the map
uh so we have detailed models of pretty
much
everywhere we were and we're just going
to scale it up and put ourselves in in
those scenes
filming us against a green screen we've
been experimenting with various ways in
order to kind of help streamline that
process the idea being that there's
going to be a lot of this footage
so we need a quick and easy way uh maybe
like we
do an auto tracking phone thing and dump
it into unreal so it's just all real
time you get the shot and it's all there
uh sam was thinking more so talking
about cam track ar when you talk about
the auto tracking phone thing
yes right we've talked about cam track
ar and just for people listening
on the most recent uh apple like event
in their big promotional video
okay yeah they featured josh davies
and cam track ar as like one of the
things for the ipad pro
which is so cool that they got like it's
going to be straight up a big
yeah like you know anytime you watch an
apple event and you're like alright they
bring on this new company and like the
ceo of that company's talking about
their new game their new app or whatever
like
josh was that guy yeah with cam track
which is super cool
cam track r i like i've been using it a
lot i used it in
i used it a couple different times in
the attack on titan video with
mixed results it's i'm having mixed
results i'll put it that way kind of
phone are you using
iphone 12 pro max oh really like
basically the nicest one um yeah this is
weird
like uh the whole like that whole one
take scene
with uh the scale of the humans uh we
filmed that with the camera on a gimbal
because
cam tracker spits out the raw image from
the sensor that
it's like oh wow yeah iphones do a lot
of post processing to their videos
including stabilization uh color all
this other stuff so
that's why that footage looks a little
less good compared to everything else
because it's like the raw sensor
anyway the idea is that this is one long
shot we don't have to camera track it
because it's already being camera
tracked while we'd go through
but the track was awful it did not work
and i think it's because
we we didn't like reset the track
between takes and so like it
got bloated but it ended up being super
easy to track in after effects literally
just one button and
the entire minute and a half take was
tracked i was like okay great
yeah for i i'm finding more uses for
cam tracker like animating things than
actually solving a camera see i feel
like cam track arr is going to prove its
use when we're on a green screen and we
don't want to deal with tracking markers
it still reads the image though but with
lighter it definitely helps it's like
it's i don't know it's just strange
it's still doing something it's like guy
rose in it too like it needs features to
track which you will have
generally speaking of filming on a green
screen regardless of whether or not
there's tracking features on the green
screen explicitly
um but i in my test pointing at a raw
green screen the points have stuck and
so i do like the idea of filming on a
green screen and not worrying about
tracking markers on the green screen at
all
so but that said matt you obviously been
really close to the son of a dungeon
edit
how are you feeling about the story in
the edit and that's a lot of fun
it's a lot of fun um i haven't been to
as close as nat has because i've only
worked on
one and a half episodes yeah or one week
fourth we keep asking matt to work on it
and then going oh wait wait wait wait
wait
work out this yeah yeah i've been on a
bunch of other stuff so
um yeah uh the main thing being the
attack on titan video that took away a
lot of my time
um but like from from the perspective of
you know i'm taking episode two and
episode four cutting it down to an hour
uh it's a lot of fun it's a lot of fun
to watch um
i think the dynamic between between all
of you and the characters is super fun
um
and it's gonna be i'm looking forward to
you know to seeing where
any uh any event stand out from the
episode that you worked on oh dude the
sports ball game is so much fun
i actually didn't edit that either but i
had to watch it because it was so funny
because i
i did shoot the whole thing so i was
there i was there the whole time so i
know the story
um that sports ball game was so much fun
i just didn't i didn't think that you
guys would actually play the game and so
it's very unexpected when it happens and
uh i love it
i don't think even we expected to
actually start playing the games like oh
i guess
all right we're doing it and then i
didn't realize that sam had had all
these rules in place
like he had actually figured out what
the game was
they didn't tell us the rules until he
didn't tell you the rules he didn't even
tell us what the game was he was just
like sports
the whole time we're all like yeah
sports it's not sport sports
it's sports ball sports ball game yeah
and it's like oh yeah by the way i
actually invented an entire sport and
made up all the rules for it
yeah just in case you guys decided to
start playing a game it totally works in
d
and with the roles and everything and we
killed our buildings just through
murder we just murdered them i mean
spoilers seriously yeah no more spoilers
yeah yeah spoiler territory there it's
okay in august people will forget about
it yeah no one's gonna remember this
there's so much that's very dense guys
so that's what happens that's a very
minor spoiler yeah yeah
i will just say one word of hype
microwave microwave microwave one more
word of height
lehman's tiny hood yeah
get 40 off your own lehman's hut we have
been chatting for a while this has been
a long time
the longest one we've ever done chunky
boy how long has it been since the start
1 45 wow we're like almost two hours in
yeah damn 45.
it's 7 p.m right now yeah all right well
thanks for joining us on your long road
trips or whatever
yeah i hope we can help you guys on a
long road trip get through the days
hey did you know that if play is a
guitar that is suppressed so we can't
hear it
okay can you hear this barely
i hear like a christian can hear it
nothing coming through well you gotta
sing if you play the music
you will feel emotion
if you play the music you will feel
emotions
[Music]
you may only hear my voice if you're
hearing me
through headphones it's really weird
it's
still such a good job and i'm like
freaking out about something that no one
else can think about
yeah they're like if you turn off your
noise suppression in discord we'll be
able to hear your guitar but oh man yeah
it's
it yeah it's so crazy because i can hear
the effort of your strumming in your
voice
but there's no strumming in the audio
yeah like
it separates the guitar and your voice
somehow that is some pretty insane
technology actually yeah that's like
that touch i did not know that was a
feature
discord i knew they had noise
suppression but like i don't know they
literally clean out the guitar while
you're playing it and singing
yeah that is pretty amazing anyway
thanks guys that was fun yeah good job
lots of fun man we dived into a lot
everybody everybody's listening to the
podcast thank you so much really
appreciate
you spend some time with us and we'll
see you in the next one
laters bye bye
bye